from some classic star wars callbacks to
some suspiciously similar gear obi-wan
kenobi packed a lot of delightful
references into its six-episode run did
you catch the legends jedi names written
in code how about the references to a
new hope if not hello there and keep
watching for the small details you
missed in obi-wan kenobi
at the beginning of obi-wan kenobi
episode 3 darth vader is shown
conducting business with his inquisitors
from his remote citadel on mustafar the
site of his greatest defeat the castle
officially known as fortress vader has
appeared once before in live action as
part of vader's ark in rogue one for the
most part though it's remained unseen in
the franchise's biggest installments
hard to see the dark side is if you've
read the darth vader comics however
you'll be much more familiar with all
the inn's announcer fortress vader not
only is the citadel constructed on the
planet where anakin skywalker fell to
his former master but it also has a
strong connection to the dark side
the fortress was designed by an ancient
sith lord named darth momen with vader
using that original design as a
blueprint for his own construction the
site of the fortress is located over an
old sith cave which connects it to the
pure energy of the dark side in this way
fortress vader represents vader's fall
as well as his complete embrace of his
sith persona spooky stuff can you use
the force on it or something
while on the transport ship from daiyu
to mapuzo obi-wan has a bit of a
restless time
the revelation that anakin survived
their duel on mustafar shakes him to his
core and despite how hard he tries he
can't reach the spirit of qui-gon jinn
through the force so what does he do to
try to calm himself in a moment when
everything feels out of control he fixes
leia's little droid friend lola after
all life's much simpler when you're
fixing things it's possible that obi-wan
simply wanted to fix the droid for
layer's sake but given that anakin has a
whole monologue in attack of the clones
about the therapeutic merits of
tinkering there's probably a lot more
going on maybe obi-wan resorts to one of
his old friend's habits to try to
assuage the guilt of his role in
anakin's fate or maybe he simply adopted
the habit of fixing things in moments of
duress after all the years he spent with
anakin either way his repair of lola is
a quietly powerful moment showing just
how deeply obi-wan grieves the loss of
his former apprentice
at one point in obi-wan kenobi episode 3
he discusses his life before joining the
jedi order he tells leia that he was
incredibly young when he was taken to
start his training so he only remembers
very brief and fleeting images from his
original life he remembers his mother's
shawl his father's hands and a baby who
he believes for being his brother the
details elude him and he doesn't even
name a home planet but it's interesting
to hear him speak even fleetingly of
this period i remember a baby a baby yes
i think i had a brother it's also
interesting that obi-wan doesn't name
his home world when talking to leia
while being interviewed by comedian and
political commentator jon stewart at a
star wars event george lucas once
claimed that obi-wan's original planet
was called stoo-jon a clear joke playing
on stuart's own name stu john
nevertheless became inserted into the
star wars law and has yet to be
officially retconned as obi-wan's birth
world
because it's set well into the imperial
era obi-wan kenobi features a lot of
gear that's pulled straight out of the
original trilogy for instance in episode
3 imperial probe droids identical to the
ones seen in the empire strikes back are
sent out to hunt for obi-wan and
princess leia
you don't have to call me that
i'm just leia
later in the same episode while
wandering the planet mapuzo obi-wan and
leia come across a couple different
squads of stormtroopers obviously their
armor and blasters are the same as they
appear in the original star wars films
but there are even smaller details worth
noticing like the tiny handheld
communicators used by the empire
soldiers identical devices are used in a
new hope during the rescue of princess
leia from the death star
the secret network of jedi allies whose
members aid obi-wan and leia in their
escape funnel fugitives to one planet in
particular jabim
ta'ala says that the agents of the path
as the secret network is called used
jabim as a place to give force sensitive
people new identities to help them evade
the empire if you're a long time star
wars fan the name jabin may ring some
bells while never an a-list planet like
tatooine or half jabim has popped up
numerous times in more extraneous star
wars media video games like star wars
the old republic and star wars empire at
war novels like republic commando triple
zero and comics like dark horses
republic series all include references
to jabim with some featuring major
storylines set on the planet
unfortunately many of those arcs have
been relegated to the non-canon legends
timeline so it's fun to see the planet
pop up in a major live-action star wars
project like the obi-wan show in legends
kenobi himself has a particular history
with jabim as it was the site of a major
military operation he led during the
clone wars while hiding out in tarla's
safe house on mapuzo obi-wan sees the
scrollings of many other jedi and
fugitives who have passed through the
planet he calls one former friend out by
name upon seeing his etchings on the
wall tala informs him that the jedi in
question helps very young force users
through the path from time to time of
course a jedi in question is quinlin vas
known during the republic era as a bit
of a loose cannon in the order vos
appears in star wars the clone wars and
is the main character of the novel star
wars dog decibel in which he has a love
affair with asajj ventress during an
undercover mission vaz frequently flirts
with the dark side and is seen as
something of a renegade as a result but
he does a lot of good during his tenure
as a jedi it's been known that he
survived order 66 in the canon so it
makes sense for his name to pop up in
obi-wan kenobi quinlan's not the only
familiar name on the walls either if
you're fluent in arabesh you might be
able to translate a few other names when
translated the names of three old jedi
appear on the walls valen halcyon a jedi
who survived order 66 and eventually
fathered a member of rogue squadron jin
altus master of luke skywalker love
interest kalista ming in the star wars
legends timeline androganda ismarin a
jedi who in the old canon turned to the
dark side all three of these characters
are pretty deep-cut references and it's
fun to see them included for fans of the
old star wars stories
episode 4 begins with a frantic montage
of obi-wan being treated for the burns
he sustained in his door with darth
vader in the previous episode tala
manages to get obi-wan out and escorts
him to a rebel base used for rescuing
four sensitive fugitives there he's
submerged in a bacter tank so that his
body can properly heal well in the bag
the tank obi-wan has flashes of anakin
seeing his old padawans severed limbs
and terrible scarring as his own it's
possible that this is simply a nightmare
caused by obi-wan's trauma and that the
specific shots of anakin in his own tank
are more for the sake of the audience
than they are actual reflections of what
obi-wan is seeing however it's also
possible that now that the two have
encountered one another again obi-wan is
seeing flashes of anakin through the
force
most of obi-wan kenobi episode iv is
spent in and around fortress
inquisitorius a secret imperial base
that houses the inquisitors constructed
in the aquatic moon of nir in the
mustafar system fortress inquisitorius
has appeared in star wars media in the
past most notably in the video game star
wars jedi fallen order in that game
which is set several years before the
events of obi-wan kenobi rogue jedi
calcus infiltrates the fortress on a
mission to secure a stolen jedi holocron
you'd think that the empire would have
stepped up security measures after that
attack but they clearly didn't think it
was necessary as obi-wan manages to
sneak in with tarla's help rescue lair
and escape in the back of a rebel ship
those who have played star wars jedi
fallen order will recognize some
specific features of fortress
inquisitorius such as the interrogation
room that leia is brought to
it's a brutal place that can break even
the strongest jedi and if the torture
fails to turn them into an inquisitor
then it also serves as a tomb obi-wan
sees a number of frozen jedi bodies
within the bowels of the fortress
including that of a youngling
in the original star wars princess leia
barely seems intimidated by her imperial
captors even after being brought to the
death star and threatened with torture
or she has a snide remarks for darth
vader and grand moff tarkin maybe that's
because a new hope isn't leia's first
experience dealing with imperial
imprisonment as shown in obi-wan kenobi
episode 4 her earliest apprehension was
at the age of 10 when she was brought to
fortress inquisitorius by the third
sister leia's childhood imprisonment
could potentially cause some
inconsistencies with the original
trilogy in terms of plot but it at least
provides an opportunity for some
parallel storytelling from her
resistance and interrogation to her
eventual rescue by obi-wan kenobi
everything about leia's arc in episode 4
feels like a mirror of her ordeal in a
new hope even at such a young age it
takes more than scary words and torture
machines to crack leia
[Music]
are you a little short for stormtrooper
in order to rescue leia from fortress
inquisitorius obi-wan has to pull out
some old tricks he infiltrates the base
from underwater using a similar small
breathing apparatus to the one he uses
and the phantom menace in that film
obi-wan's subaquatic journey takes him
to the land of the gungans despite the
heightened stakes obi-wan's old tricks
seem to be just as effective as ever
later on while moving through the
fortress itself obi-wan uses the force
to distract two stormtroopers with a
conspicuous sound it's an identical move
to the one he uses on the death star in
a new hope which also ends up helping
him save leia's life though there's a
good decade between the show and the
movie the empire's soldiers don't seem
to get any smarter or maybe old ben is
just too damn good
what do you call a snow speeder when
it's not in the snow you use its
technical name of course the t47
airspeeder obi-wan drops the ship's
numerical designation early in episode
four when talking to rokin and the
foreshadowing comes to fruition at the
end of the episode as mentioned in the
empire strikes back the t-47s aren't
really designed for cold weather in the
first place in fact they have to be
specifically augmented to work on hearth
at all and they're barely ready by the
time the empire attacks a rebel base
there it's pretty fun to see the
airspeeders operating in their intended
non-freezing environment because the
rebel alliance isn't really a thing yet
to drain the events of obi-wan kenobi
there's no guarantee that rokin speeders
are the ones seen on half but since he's
clearly willing to go to bat against the
empire there's definitely a chance
obi-wan kenobi episode 5 begins with a
flashback to the prequel era showing
obi-wan and anakin sparring in a
practice duel at khorasan's jedi temple
the fight is returned to at various
points throughout the episode and there
are a number of fun little details for
fans to watch for because anakin still
has his padawan's braid the scene
presumably takes place in the days
leading up to attack of the clones at
one point anakin chastises obi-wan for
losing his weapon a conversation that
happens the other way around in episode
2 despite the fact that obi-wan also
constantly loses his lightsaber there
are also some specific callbacks in the
choreography such as anakin's barrage of
heavy overhead swings a move used on him
by luke in return of the jedi the
flashback fight also helps fix what
could have been a minor plothole in the
last shot of the door obi-wan tells
anakin your need to prove yourself is
your undoing until you overcome it a
padawan you will still be anakin
reflects on this lesson as he watches
obi-wan escape from jabim presumably
taking it to heart this explains how
this line from a new hope still makes
sense when i left you i was about to
learn now i am the master episode 5 also
features some additional revenge of the
sith flashbacks after the revelation
that riva is a former youngling and
order 66 survivor hayden christensen
ends up playing several different
versions of anakin which is fun to see
for fans of the prequels
flashbacks aren't the only place obi-wan
returns to his clone wars self in
obi-wan kenobi episode 5. after spending
most of the series in hiding and
hesitating to assert himself or use his
powers the exiled jedi finally steps up
and takes charge when he learns that
darth vader is coming to attack the
outpost on jabin he quickly organizes
those in the base securing any possible
routes of entry in an attempt to buy as
much time as possible coming immediately
after the prequel flashbacks this moment
clearly harkens back to obi-wan's days
as general kenobi in the clone wars
anyone who's seen the animated series
will be familiar with his extensive
resume as a military commander and that
experience helps him out against vader's
attack when he needs it most old ben's
days of proper fighting may be long
behind him but he's still capable of
jumping into action from time to time
it's always interesting to see which
ships weapons and assorted gadgets
return in new star wars stories and the
obi-wan show has several in episode 5
two classic tools of the trade stick out
in particular rokin's bowcaster and
tarla's thermal detonator the bowcaster
is most famous as chewbacca's weapon of
choice through the star wars saga in
fact it's largely considered to be a
wookiee weapon as many of koshig's other
denizens are seen wielding it throughout
the franchise frozen's weapon is a
little different from the traditional
bowcaster with a long barrel and a few
other design changes it's unclear if he
made the modifications himself or if
this is simply a different model of the
weapon perhaps one more common for
non-wookiees
tala's thermal detonator provides a bit
of a darker easter egg in obi-wan kenobi
episode 5. after receiving what she
knows to be a fatal shot she decides to
seal the next blast door and detonate
the weapon a small grenade-like device
that releases a devastating explosion
thermal detonators have made several
prominent appearances in star wars
before most famously in return of the
jedi when a disguised layer threatens
jabba the hutt with one given that
tala's sacrifice helps save leia's life
that's kind of poetic again it's like
poetry so if they rhyme
one of the main points of obi-wan kenobi
is showing how ewan mcgregor's version
of the character evolves into the old
master played by alec guinness it's a
pretty severe transformation and as the
disney plus series is set midway between
revenge of the sith and the new hope
it's a perfect context to show how the
hero's transition comes about after a
lot of clear guilt and hopelessness in
the first half of the series obi-wan
finally starts to find himself again in
episode 5. the patience and faith with
which he manipulates reaver and vader
feel very true to guinness's obi-wan and
his increasingly haggard appearance
visually symbolizes that internal
transformation later in episode 5
obi-wan even evokes his original
incarnation with a line there are other
ways to fight a pretty clear reference
to guinnesses there are alternatives to
fighting he's certainly been through a
lot but the exiled obi-wan finally
starts acting more and more like the
wise and old ben obi-wan's philosophy
also stands in stark contrast to vedas
anakin typically only sees one way to
fight a full-on assault it's the flaw
that makes him lose the battle on
mustafar and it's the flaw that allows
obi-wan and rokin's group to escape
the climax of obi-wan kenobi episode v
is a lightsaber duel between river and
darth vader or rather the duel where
riva uses her lightsabers and vader
mainly uses the force to defeat her it's
a tense fight that perfectly shows just
how powerful anakin is with the dark
side and it ends in a shot that
parallels one of the most important
moments in his downfall after a brief
scuffle vader swipes both of riva's
sabers and knocks her to the ground
standing over her with one blade in each
hand to finish her off it's the exact
same position that anakin and count
dooku find themselves in at the end of
their duel in revenge of the sith after
beating the old villain anakin takes his
lightsaber and holds both weapons to
dooku's throat at the goading of
chancellor and soon to be emperor
palpatine anakin makes a killing blow a
violation of the jedi code that
foreshadows his eventual turn clearly
anakin is just as capable in his mask
and armor though he does leave riva to
die with her head still attached
in the obi-wan kenobi finale owen lars
and luke skywalker head into town to buy
a new belt for their speeder as luke
apparently broke the old one the scene
only goes on for a couple of lines
before owen learns of reba's return
which sparked some of the main action of
the episode in that brief moment
beforehand though the viewers get a
glimpse of luke's early life on tatooine
because moisture farming isn't exactly a
job for the super rich it's safe to
assume that the speeder luke and owen
mention is the same one scene in a new
hope the one that luke takes into the
desert with c-3po to chase down r2d2 of
course that adventure ultimately leads
to a run-in with obi-wan it's also a fun
little detail that luke's the one who
broke the speeder belt he's his father's
son after all and even at such a young
age he's clearly quite the reckless
pilot
obi-wan kenobi episode vi delivers a new
full-length lightsaber duel between the
eponymous jedi and darth vader which
ends in victory for obi-wan the two
confront each other on a barren rocky
battleground vader taunts his old master
by asking him if he intends to destroy
him in response obi-wan ignites his
lightsaber and strikes a bose that
should be instantly recognizable to
prequel fans with his blade held
aggressively over his head and his
offhand extended out toward his opponent
obi-wan mirrors his stance at the start
of his revenge of the sith fight against
general grievous paired with a familiar
stance is a familiar line uttered in
response to vader's challenge i will do
what i must another revenge of the sith
reference this line is the same one
spoken by obi-wan just before his and
anakin's daughter mustafar though he
nearly perishes at the hands of his old
apprentice obi-wan finds a second wind
in his battle with vader after
remembering his obligation to protect
luke and leia reinvigorated he unleashes
a brutal barrage of attacks on the sith
eventually cleaving his foe's helmet and
twain and revealing anakin's burnt skull
beneath the sight of his old friend and
the sound of his voice paralyzes obi-wan
and he quickly begins to apologize for
having failed anakin but vader rejects
his pity saying you didn't kill anakin
skywalker i did this is an important
moment for obi-wan's overall arc as it
shows him accepting his past decisions
and moving on from his guilt it also
ties into a new hope in a fun way but
luke first joins up with ben in that
movie the old jedi tells him that darth
vader betrayed and murdered luke's
father previously the line read as an
outright lie but now in the face of what
happens in obi-wan kenobi ben's certain
point of view on the fate of his friend
is much clearer the young princess leia
gets a lot of screen time in obi-wan
kenobi and she eventually makes her way
back to aldoran in the finale the fact
that she survives at all is pretty
impressive given everything that she's
been through and she comes home more
than a little changed those ceremonial
robes and dresses she's supposed to wear
gone
instead we get a brief montage of leia
dressing herself in a versatile white
outfit with high boots and tardis
holster while it's not exactly the same
outfit that leia wears in a new hope is
very reminiscent of that iconic white
look which is clearly by design there's
also some similarities to one of padme's
outfits from attack of the clones and
since obi-wan leaves leia with a few
kind words about her mother that makes
sense it's a cute little moment that
pays tribute to both the character's
future and her past and let's be honest
leia looks adorable
after their battle anakin and obi-wan
once again retreat to their respective
corners of the galaxy the former to move
safar and the latter to tatooine the
show then gives us a nice little bit of
parallelism between the two as each of
them has a short consultation scene with
their master vader speaks with emperor
palpatine via hologram from its citadel
and obi-wan finally manages to establish
contact with qui-gon jinn these two
cameos are fun enough on their own
merits as it's cool just to see ian
mcdermott and liam neeson back in the
star wars fold again but using them in
this parallel way as an extra texture
reaffirming the show's core theme of
masters and apprentices both characters
look pretty spot-on to their old
incarnations with palpatine rocking his
signature black hood and qui-gon
sporting his old jedi robes and long
hair the emperor even gets to use one of
his old original trilogy lines asking
vader if he's sure his thoughts on the
whole obi-wan situation are clear
after such a serious six-episode span
why not end obi-wan kenobi with a meme
when the battle with vader is over and
riva ends her vengeful crusade obi-wan
decides to move out of his old cave for
somewhere a little nicer he stops by
owen and baru's moisture farm to touch
base beforehand and in a surprising
display of kindness owen asks if he
wants to meet luke of course obi-wan
jumps at the chance and approaches the
boy while he's fiddling with some piece
of the farm's machinery we don't get to
see the actual exchange but we do see
obi-wan open the conversation
hello there
a simple phrase has become one of the
characters most famous over the years
both because it's his first spoken line
in the entire franchise and because it
returns in the prequels having obi-wan
speed the line again to end his own show
is certainly an interesting choice and
it sets him up as a friendly old man he
later becomes
obi-wan kenobi starts out in a flashback
set during revenge of the sith
specifically the brutal assaults on the
jedi temple led by anakin skywalker a
scene shows a class of jedi younglings
training with a master in the ways of
the force when clone troopers attacked
the class the master escorts her
students through the halls of the temple
taking down several attacking clone
troopers along the way tragically she
doesn't make it far before dying to a
well-placed blaster bolt leaving the
younglings to fend for themselves in
addition to showing the new angle on the
events of order 66 the flashback scene
includes a couple of details that most
fans of the star wars prequels should
recognize the helmets that the
younglings are wearing for instance are
the same ones worn by yoda students in
attack of the clones the layout of the
jedi temple as shown in the escape
sequence also perfectly mirrors its
portrayal and the prequel trilogy
finally the order 66 scene sets the
stage for the gross imbalance of power
rampant drone the imperial era some of
the younglings may have survived but
they would either become fugitives or
imperial inquisitors what do we do now
we run
disney plus has returned to tatooine
again and again in its various star wars
shows and while obi-wan quickly makes
his way off the desert planet in his own
series he spends a whole first episode
wandering the dune sea at this point
jawas and panthers are a little too
commonplace to count as easter eggs but
there are still some fun details waiting
to be found the saloon that the
inquisitors infiltrate is a nice homage
to the maasai's lee cantina complete
with bright green drinks served in tall
opaque glasses obi-wan's java friend
tikka references the juntland wastes
which any good star wars fan knows are
not to be travelled lightly
additionally there's a good sampling of
the local tatooine wildlife
obi-wan earns a living by working on a
butcher line harvesting meat from the
massive corpse of what appears to be a
crate dragon or some similarly massive
beast his cruel overseer might conjure
memories of rey's portion paying boss in
the force awakens it's then revealed
that obi-wan's main mode of transport is
an eop a long-standed camel-like
creature first introduced in the phantom
menace eobs have historically been best
known for their flatulence but obi-wan
seems to have required one with more
decorum
obi-wan kenobi episode 1 paints a pretty
grim picture of the jedi's life in exile
after a hard day at work he returns his
hideout in the desert which is little
more than a furnished cave still even
amid the barrenness obi-wan has retained
some reminders of his old life which
includes some interesting references to
the star wars movies at the entrance to
his home there's a periscope scanner
presumably a security protocol to alert
him to intruders
fans may recognize the device's design
as an identical periscope is used
repeatedly by r2d2 throughout the star
wars films hopefully obi-wans are simply
a repurposed gadget and not the
appendage of some poor astro megdroid
burrowed in the sun
later in episode 1 obi-wan takes out an
old hologram communicator to receive a
transmission from bale or ghana it's
another device that should be familiar
to those who have seen the movies as
obi-wan is seen using it in the prequel
trilogy perhaps most striking of all
however is the cloud of defeat that
follows obi-wan under his bend persona
the jedi truly looks like he's given up
he's buried his and anakin's lightsaber
in the desert in what is a possible
allusion to the end of the rise of
skywalker he's terrorized by nightmares
and he is hesitant to use the force in
basically any scenario given how calm
and controlled obi-wan is in a new hope
it's interesting to see him in such a
dark place
if you've absorbed much star wars media
in the disney era then you're probably
familiar with the imperial inquisitors
moses ingram's reaver who takes a
villainous lead in the disney plus
series is a new addition but some of the
emperor's agents have appeared in the
past sung kang's fifth brother for
instance has featured in several
previous projects including the darth
vader comics and star wars rebels he
eventually meets his end at the hands of
darth maul a curious twist to fate given
their shared history of hunting for
obi-wan the grand inquisitor another
prominent villain from the star wars
comics and star wars rebels also makes
his presence felt in the obi-wan show
however he's a bit different this time
around in star wars rebels the grand
inquisitor is voiced by jason isaacs and
some fans were upset when he was recast
with rupert friend for the live-action
version after being stabbed by reaver in
a surprising betrayal though the grand
inquisitor's fade seems up in the air
it's possible that he'll survive the
attack but it's also possible that
friend's character is a different
version of the villain and the isaac's
rendition in rebels might be some sort
of clone it is star wars after all
regardless both the fifth brother and
the grand inquisitor wield the same
spinning lightsabers first shown in star
wars rebels and they look a bit more
intimidating in live action
one of the more touching moments in
obi-wan kenobi episode 1 comes during
ben's interaction with tikka the jawa he
spends a good portion of his hard-earned
money to buy a toy for the young luke
skywalker and not just any toy either
specifically obi-wan purchases a model
of a t-16 skyhopper a small airspeeder
first mentioned in the original star
wars luke references the craft during
the briefing for the first death star
attack claiming that but it's not
impossible i used to bullseye womp rats
in my t-16 back home he's also shown
playing with a toy version of the
speeder during an early conversation
with c-3po it seems that obi-wan was the
giver of that gift all along which is a
fun little twist on a tiny piece of
pre-existing lore though luke's uncle
owen insists that obi-wan takes the toy
back it seems that he acquiesces in the
end
a lot of star wars media has dealt with
luke's time on tatooine but far less
time has been spent exploring his sister
leia's upbringing on old iran obi-wan
kenobi addresses that by spending time
on the planet following a ten-year-old
layer through the ins and outs of her
real life young star vivian lyra blair
does an excellent job bringing the young
princess to life complete with leia's
signature snark stubborn nurse and wet
in one scene while climbing a tree with
her little droid friend lola leia starts
naming the ships she sees leaving the
local spaceport
napoleon ranger probably scouting for
murson pirates the mention of aquilian
rangers is a deep cut reference to the
aquilae first mentioned in an infamous
cut line from the original star wars the
sun pirates appear in some early star
wars comics that have since been
relegated to the legends timeline though
they have also been referenced in
canonical media it's also worth noting
that in an attempt to avoid her adoptive
parents impending political reception
leia sends a young decoy to be dressed
and ornamented in her place the exact
same tactic her mother padme used many
times throughout her political career
leia quickly reminds obi-wan of padme
after they meet and it's clear why
soon after arriving on the crime-ridden
world of daiyu obi-wan sees a face he
certainly didn't expect
that of an old clone trooper begging for
money on the side of a dirty street
though the former republic soldier is
technically much younger than obi-wan he
looks notably older as his body has
broken down due to the camino wins
accelerated aging alterations
it's a powerful reminder of what
happened to the clones after the rise of
the empire as shown in star wars the bad
batch most were quickly phased out of
military service it's clearly jarring
for obi-wan to see the old clone which
makes sense giving his complicated
history with them on the one hand he
probably saw his old friends cody and
rex in the beggar's face and he felt a
deep sadness on the other hand the
events of order 66 would surely have
created a traumatic connection to the
clones obi-wan moves on from the
encounter quickly but it surely stays
with him especially since the clone's
blue accented armor is remarkably
similar to rexus
if there's underworld activity happening
in a star wars story there's a good
chance it has something to do with spice
the all-purpose drug signifier taken
straight from june that rule holds true
in obi-wan kenobi as well with the spice
trade rearing its head immediately on
dayu a young dealer tries to sell the
rogue jedi some of the stuff naming a
few different varieties including kessel
a primary space planet most famous for
the kessel run and felucian a reference
to the planet felucia where jedi ailer
sakura meta and fortune attend drawing
order 66
later on obi-wan infiltrates a spice lab
and even uses a vial of the stuff to
fend off a group of would-be captors he
smashes a small glass container on the
ground and locks his attackers in with
it
sending them all on what looks to be a
pretty intense trip
less on easter egg than a fun little
detail this one's still worth mentioning
given the main character in the series
in the original star wars ben kenobi
describes lightsabers in an interesting
way an elegant weapon
for a more
civilized day
this line is referenced again in revenge
of the sith after obi-wan discards her
used blaster and declares it so
uncivilized it's interesting then that
he uses blasters so prevalently in the
first couple of episodes of his own show
as he doesn't want to out himself as a
jedi obi-wan hesitates to use either the
force or his lightsaber he instead
relies on his martial arts prowess and
what weapons he can find to keep the bad
guys at bay more importantly obi-wan
doesn't complain once about the blasters
he's forced to use almost as if he's had
to let go of his old jedi pride it's a
small detail but it helps build the
sense that he's really given up all hope
if obi-wan kenobi can use a blaster
without a snide comment things truly
have taken a dark turn
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
obi-wan kenobi are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]